i would like to take a moment now to
briefly update
on the latest advice on the pfizer
biontech vaccine
which we approved in early december
so the next slide please summarizes
the updated guidance on the use of the
pathiso biontech vaccine
particularly in pregnancy and women who
are breastfeeding
in people with allergies and also
on the dose interval taking first
pregnancy and women who are
breastfeeding
our advice to date has been that given
that an initial lack of evidence on a
precautionary basis
use of the vaccine wasn't recommended in
pregnancy
and women with breastfeeding should not
be given the vaccine
but now that we have reviewed further
data that has become available
the commission on human medicines has
advised that the vaccine can be
considered for use in pregnancy
when the potential benefits outweigh the
risks following an
individual discussion with every woman
and as the covid19 vaccine astrazeneca
is the same women should always be
discussing benefits and risks of having
the vaccine
with their health professional reaching
a decision together
based on individual circumstances and
women who are breastfeeding
can now also be given the vaccine
subject to
that individual discussion
turning to people with allergies we
previously issued advice that people
with a range of allergies
to food to vaccines to other medicines
should not
be given the fisa biontech vaccine
but there is now growing evidence in a
much wider pool of people who've had the
vaccine
at least eight hundred thousand in the
uk probably a million and a half in the
usa
which has raised no additional concerns
and gives us further assurance that the
risk of
anaphylaxis can be managed through
standard clinical guidance
and an observation period following
vaccination
of at least 15 minutes and so the
commission on human medicines has now
advised
that anyone with allergy to food or
other medicine or vaccine
can have the fisa bionic vaccine
of course anyone with a history of
allergic reaction
to this vaccine or its ingredients
should not
finally the dose interval the commission
on human medicines
on further review of the data has
recommended that the second dose
is at least 21 days
after the first so this allows for a
potentially longer
interval compared with the previous
advice
that was 21 days and the conditions
for use of the fisa biontech vaccine
stress
that this is in accordance with national
guidance so those are the updates on the
fisa biontech covid19 vaccine
they mean that even more people are now
eligible
for vaccination